this is Startalk Chuck you know this is
a very exciting time here at Startalk
radio because this is a maker edition
yes it is right brought to you by Google
that's correct
forget making science dot with
google.com it's where you can't get
involved in the whole maker vibe that's
another we had another query yes we do
have another query let's uh let's read
this one from Tom Rix from Tom Rex Tom
Rix from Facebook would like to know
this he says Bill Nye the Science Guy
yes how long do you think it will be
before we can print a 3d agricultural
crop in order to reduce co2 emissions
and water consumption we have all the
ingredients right so he's talking about
forget blowing the space and printing
something can we print something here
and now namely food yeah I thought he
wanted to print a crop he does he wants
to aggress it once to our agricultural
crops in order to reduce co2 emissions
and water consumption which is which is
very important so Tom I've I think I
follow you but you're you what if I
understand this you want to eat a 3d
printed plant yes so you I mean right at
our current state of the art you're
gonna be eating plastic okay why would
you put the crop out in the Sun if it's
3d printed and stuff like that so we may
have once again if I can use the verb
conflate it a couple ideas very
reasonable that you'll be able to 3d
print beads that hold water in the soil
right so that there's less evaporation
that's very reasonable to me or maybe
even a a mat for planning your crops
akin to mulch plastic mulch do you want
to may know you had two wraps traps the
moisture yeah yeah and keeps weeds from
coming through the moisture doesn't
evaporate back into the atmosphere right
but you don't want to have it too sealed
up then you get fungi of various brands
yes so I think I know what you're
driving is
out of my sneakers that's a lot of
information showing so we I think I know
what you're driving up we would have
custom-made mulch mats to plant our
crops in and they could be 3d printed
the mulch mats so there is an
application you know his idea may have
been slightly askew but there is an
application for 3d printing in
agricultural oh man heavens yes just
like suppose you one of the things you
got to learn I think as a farmer is
welding this is to say when stuff breaks
those people are continually repairing
things yeah discs and Haros and things
you know what not see what you just said
there just struck in me a little chord
because it seems like every movie or
television show that you watch where the
people are out on a farm and they're
like have all these acres around them
anything that breaks they immediately
start to go in and fix it the tractor
breaks they fix you never see them call
somebody
tractor Co everything arm guy skills I
guess farm gal skills and so it's very
reasonable that you would have 3d
printers for farm equipment and and so
what I'm imagining and then I to long
future truck not that it's all about
Bill and his imagination we're
responding to is it Tom's question this
is yes
Tom Rix yes that I'm imagining a time
when something breaks in your house or
your apartment and instead of ordering
the spare part and having it shipped to
you you go down to the spiritual
equivalent of FedEx Kinkos or staples
and at that place they make you a new
part just make their big 3d printer
which they have air-cooled and is large
and very accurate you don't have to have
one at home right and then in the same
way certain gear heads keep a collection
of wrenches around right it'll be
certain gear head type people that have
a 3d printer at home I know guys with
milling machines and lathes at home so
there'll be that sort of culture I can
understand it but I wouldn't be
surprised if they're big ones some day
in the not-too-distant future for
repairing farm equipment sure okay it on
going on but you don't want to eat what
it's what's precious what threw me off a
little probably not they had the
application is
mostly for assisting in but I can
imagine 3d printing some candy right yes
because you're easy melt the sugar the
same way why not ask and you print out
some 3d printed seaweed I mean I seems
very resi plant seems very reasonable
but why you would do that rather than
growing plants directly okay I have to
think it through but that's a cool
question Tom so tom cool question and
the answer is candy you'll be able to
print candy mmm it's gonna be dandy this
is Startalk